Avengers infinity war ended with the
biggest downer since the Empire Strikes
Back so it's no wonder that everyone's
trying to figure out what's going to
happen when Thanos returns to the screen
in 2019 from Clues we've picked up in
the comics to hints that we've already
seen here are our predictions for the
possible outcomes of Avengers 4 spoiler
warning were going to be talking a lot
about the end of infinity war the new
black panther the most shocking part of
infinity war came when Thanos snapped
his fingers and killed half the universe
and it only got more surprising when it
turned out that that half included
heroes like spider-man
Bucky dr. strange and the Black Panther
since there are about 1.3 billion
reasons and Counting to keep that last
guy around we're guessing that most of
these deaths are probably going to be
undone by the end of Avengers 4 another
judge see I am NOT that even if it's
just for now though to chalice death
leads to the most obvious idea for the
next one
shuri becoming the new black panther
with the heart-shaped herbs gone at the
end of black panther cherie would be
able to use her expertise and technology
to step into the role we've even seen
her in action fighting with panther
shaped energy gauntlets all she needs is
the costume the other strong possibility
would be that Nakia takes over instead
but Sheree is the one who becomes Black
Panther in the comics went to Chawla is
incapacitated with Marvel Studios track
record of using elements from stories
like Winter Soldier and Infinity
Gauntlet as road maps that seems like
the one they'd want to stick with king
of the Dead
if Sheree does become the Black Panther
that leaves us with the question of what
could happen with to Chawla we're pretty
sure he's going to come back to life
somehow but something in the comics
gives another possibility he might just
become the king of the Dead in the
comics
T'Challa found himself conflicted after
Shuri took over as the leader of Wakanda
he wanted to be Black Panther again but
he doesn't want to interfere with
sharees reign obviously he solves this
problem by going to the secret
necropolis under the Golden City so that
he can talk to bast the cat goddess you
know pretty standard cat stuff to give
him a new purpose she made him king of
the dead with all the strength and
wisdom of every black panther before him
who better to lead a team of superheroes
back to the land of the
I am a scarred reborn infinity wars
shocks aren't limited to the end of the
movie right at the beginning we find out
that Thanos and the Black Order killed
all the Asgardian refugees that Thor
worked so hard to save in Ragnarok that
might not be the end of Asgard though in
the comics Ragnarok isn't the end of the
world it's the end of a cycle as gods
Thor and the other s Guardians are
creatures of mythology they live die and
are reborn in the new forms eternally
bound by their nature if we're following
that logic then the next major quest for
a Thor who's more powerful than ever
could be the rebuilding of Asgard by
tracking down the reborn souls of the
other gods including an all-new
all-different Loki the return of Korg me
and Valkyrie they couldn't really kill
the three best new movie characters of
2017 off screen between movies could
they until proven otherwise let's just
assume that Korg meet and Valkyrie
weren't on the refugee ship for some
reason maybe they were out scouting for
groceries or fighting the Skrulls
anything to get them back for next time
seriously if happy Hogan can be in like
six of these movies then Valkyrie needs
to be in at least ten Tony Stark
r.i.p a lot of moviegoers predicted we'd
be bidding a fond farewell to Robert
Downey jr. and infinity war that didn't
happen this time but it may have been
set up for Avengers for Doctor Strange
traded Thanos the time stone in exchange
for sparing Tony Stark's life that's
surprising first because Strange swore
an oath to protect it and second because
he did it knowing that if Thanos got the
stones he was going to kill half the
galaxy anyway even a strange and Stark
we're BFFs and not just dudes who didn't
actually seem to like each other there
is no way anyone should trade Iron Man's
life for uncountable trillions unless
shortly before that scene is the one
where strange uses the time stone to
take a peek at 14 million alternate
outcomes and says that the good guys
only win in one given the bargain he
makes you have to assume that the one
reality where Thanos is defeated has to
be the one where Tony Stark lives long
enough to do something to turn the tide
we're betting it's a heroic sacrifice
that's been building for 11 years
the all-new Iron Man Tony Stark might be
on the way out but Iron Man could stick
around it's just going to be Jim Rhodes
under the helmet instead like Sheree
this one follows the precedent set in
the comics before he was more machine
roadie was Iron Man from 1983 to 1985 it
also seems like a logical continuation
of the story he's the only one besides
Tony to fight in the Ironman armor and
the big airport battle in civil war left
him injured beating Starks tech to walk
that puts him in a very similar position
to the way Tony was back in his early
comics appearances when he needed his
armor to keep his heart beating
if Rhodey does take over that provides
proof of concept for the idea that the
MCU can continue after the departure of
big-name actors something that was
already done on a small scale when Don
Cheadle took over the role of Rhodey
from Terrence Howard next time keep
waiting for Adam warlock Adam warlock is
a huge part of the original Infinity
Gauntlet story while his role for the
most part is limited to standing around
in space watching the big battle go down
he actually winds up in possession of
the gauntlet itself at the end between
that and its imminent arrival being
teased in the post-credits scene of
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 it might
have been surprising that he didn't make
an appearance in infinity war
he's even the focal point of the comic
book crossover that gave the movie its
name if you're thinking they might have
saved him for the sequel though it
doesn't seem likely one of the few
movies to have actually been announced
for the next phase of Marvel movies was
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 with Adam
being set up as ayisha's genetically
engineered instrument of revenge it's
way more likely that he'll show up there
that leaves the role open for a
spacefaring hero who can explain
galactic conflicts and it seems pretty
obvious that it's going to go to Captain
Marvel who was summoned at the end of
infinity war by Nick Fury's cosmic
beeper that makes sense structurally
since Captain Marvel and ant-man in the
wasp are the only MCU movies coming out
between infinity war and adventures for
as much as we like Scott Lang he's not
the guy who's going to be getting
everyone up to speed on the kree-skrull
war Carol Danvers on the other hand has
experienced battling against and
wielding exactly the kind of cosmic
power that the heroes are going to
need to beat Thanos once and for all
that leaves the Guardians free to fly
back into their own movie and the only
question left is whether they'll fight
Adam warlock or the Magus who is Adam
warlock evil self from an alternate
future comic books can be pretty
complicated cat wolf at last will admit
that this one's pretty unlikely but if
infinity war has proven anything it's
that the Marvel movies can do anything
and make a billion dollars they've spent
ten full years and nineteen movies
getting to that point but they just put
out a movie about a giant purple man
trying to get his hands on magic space
rocks featuring characters like Proxima
midnight and the collector and a major
plot point was that a space dwarf made a
magic hammer out of a talking tree Rock
complaining but you have to admit that
stuff's pretty weird clearly there's
nothing stopping them from doing a movie
where Captain America becomes a
super-powered werewolf and delivers an
inspirational speech to a bunch of other
werewolves it might even make sense from
the moviemaking standpoint if Chris
Evans really wants to scale back his
acting work and devote his time to
remodeling his house then why not
replace him with the CGI Wolfman with an
indestructible shield it would
definitely be a weird direction to lift
from the comics but they already did the
part where Thanos starts turning people
into cubes there's no way a wolf is any
weirder than that thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]